devenu ce pactole si c'est melissa
maulin depuis cette semaine je reçus une
question d' anthony qui me demandent
comment parce que les politiciens
agissent avec vous depuis la création
des écoles nos morts anthony c'est une
bonne question parce que sa salive
beaucoup de répercussions le mouvement
mais c'était pas le premier mouvement
autochtone comme un mythe d'autres
mouvances des premières nations qui
existait avant l'arrivée d'un au moment
une des mauvaises qu'on voit beaucoup en
action ses seules des la pnq elle au
québec c'est l'assemblée des premières
nations du québec et du labrador ça
c'est l'assemblée des chefs qui se
réunissent et qui comme parce par ce
canal peuvent parler justement avec les
politiciens que ce soit au niveau
fédéral ou provincial
quand on pense alors mémoire c'est quand
même depuis 2012
le changement de ton ont quand même été
très grand faut pas oublier qu'en 2012
les mobilisateurs d'arraisonnement un
test sous surveillance des services
intelligence canadienne donc un peu des
espions du canal pour nous surveiller
mais l'année dernière on a été nommé
dans un top 10 des premières nations à
surveiller justement comme étant des
exemples de sites web
pourquoi c'est parce que il n'ya rien
six ans personne savait presque rien sur
les communautés personne savait rien sur
nos monuments une mobilisation sur nos
mobilisateur on connaissait les
personnes avec qui on parle est
habituellement c'est à dire l'apn la pnq
elle met les gens l'arrière était moins
connu c'est pas la faute de l'apn la
percu elle c'était quand même la faute
de ne pas avoir eu d'intérêt par rapport
à ce qui se passait dans les communautés
alors en six ans ce qui a changé c'est
que les gens ont commencé à dire aux
faudrait peut-être on porte attention et
les politiciens en premier parce que les
des enjeux qui se passe sur les
communautés mais les enjeux ni
programmation touche aussi les milieux
urbains et les milieux urbains ce ne
sont pas des réserves
ce sont des centres qu'on partage et les
enjeux du programme nations vont venir
dans font couler dans dans la rivière
qui est non autochtone et la néo
politiciens il ya une manière de le
faire qui aurait pu être négative est
une manière de travailler qui peut être
positive donc c'est certain qu'ils ne
veulent pas tomber dans la
mêmes erreurs qu avant 2012 et créer le
même genre de discrimination ou de
rapport de force qui existe est et qui
ne doit plus perpétuer donc on voit des
commissions présentement qui existe ce
soit comme ça pour les femmes
assassinées disparus ou la commission
vient sur les relations avec les
services publics et les commissions
malheureusement il faut parce qu'il faut
réparer l'erreur d'oubli qui a été si
longue
donc je dirais que la relation avec les
politiciens a beaucoup changé
c'est certain qu'on n'est pas encore des
nations qui vont être impliqués dans la
politique non autochtone mais on
extrêmement impliqué dans la politique
autochtone donc c'est certain que la
porte est ouverte par exemple pour
beaucoup plus de discussions et de plus
en plus de personnes des premières
nations vont se présenter dans les
milieux politiques
mais c'est vraiment une nouvelle
relation et je pense qu'au québec on a
la chance de dire qu elle est beaucoup
plus positif que peut elle être des fois
dans d'autres provinces du canada
alors j'espère qu'elle va continuer à
s'améliorer j'espère que j'ai pu
répondre à ta question anthony et
j'espère surtout vous allez pas hésité à
partager une vidéo est nous envoyer vos
questions à paroles autochtone souhaite
une belle semaine